WE HAVE.
ONE CHANGE WE HAVE A PROPOSED WE
HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
FIRST TIME THIS YEAR.
FILE ITEM TO SB FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
WILL BE MOVED TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
WITH THAT WE ARE A SUB CURRENTLY
A SUB COMMITTEE BUT THIS ITEM IS
FOR TESTIMONY ONLY WHY DON'T WE
MOVE TO FILE ITEM.
SEVEN SB TWO NINETY FOUR SENATOR
HILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR IN
THE COLLEAGUES.
I WANT TO START BY THANKING YOU
AND YOUR STAFF THEY'VE DONE A
WONDERFUL JOB WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOUR OFFICE ON CRAFT
IN THE LANGUAGE TO ALLOW FOR
THESE.
THESE CHARITIES TO EXEMPT A PRO
RATED PORTION OF THEIR PROPERTY
TAXES AS DESCRIBED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND COMMENT H..
AND ALSO HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
LOWERED THE CAP OF ONE HUNDRED
MILLION AS SUGGESTED IN COMMON
QUE.
SB TWO NINETY FOUR WILL AID NON
PROFITS AND RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BY EXPANDING THE PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION TO ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN A SAYS PROPERTY ABOUT
THE PROPERTY ANNUALLY.
SPECIFICALLY IT WILL HELP A VERY
DESERVING CHARITY FROM DAY ONE
WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT.
YOU'RE ALL AWARE FOUR OUT OF
FIVE LEAST AFFORDABLE RENTAL
MARKETS NATIONWIDE ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
NON PROFITS THAT DID NOT RECEIVE
ANY TAX CREDITS OR LOANS FROM
THE STATE OR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES HAVE A
CAP PLACED ON THE AMOUNT OF
PROPERTY TAX IT MAY BE EXEMPTED
ANNUALLY.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROVIDERS
THAT DO RECEIVE TAX CREDITS OR
LOANS FROM H. CD HAVE NO LIMIT
ON THE AMOUNT OF PROPERTY TAXES
THAT CAN BE EXEMPTED.
AND NO MINIMUM PERCENTAGE
REQUIRED OF TENANTS WHO ARE LOW
INCOMEIN ORDER TO RECEIVE A PRO
RATED PORTION OF THE PROPERTY
TAXES EXEMPTED.
THE REQUESTED SAMITY OAK OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY ASSESSOR'S OFFICE.
IN IN SB TWO NINETY FOUR WE
LOWERED THE THRESHOLD FOR
NONPROFITS. TO RECEIVE A
PROPERTY TAX BENEFIT THE SAINT
FRANCIS CENTER IN MY DISTRICT
RECENTLY WAS ABLE TO ACQUIRE A
FORTY EIGHT UNIT.
APARTMENTCOMPLEX ALL WITH
PRIVATE DONATIONS.
AT A COST OF TWENTY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THE BUILDING HAD EXISTING
TENANTS IN BECAUSE OF HOW TIGHT
AND EXPENSE OF THE BAY AREA
RENTAL MARKET IS THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO IMMEDIATELY AFFECT ALL
OF THE TENANTS THAT WERE NOT LOW
INCOME.
AND THEY PAY THE PRICE THEY
RECEIVE THE TAX BILL OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE COUNTY.
WITH THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S OFFICE CALLED MY
OFFICE AND REQUESTED THAT THE
SAINT FRANCIS CENTER.
AND OTHER SIMILARLY SITUATED
CHARITIES GET A PRO RATED
PORTION OF THEIR PROPERTY TAXES
EXEMPTED AS LONG AS THEY HAVE AT
LEAST. 50% OF LOWINCOME TENANTS
AND I AGREED WITH THEM IT'S ONLY
FAIR AND IT MAKES SENSE.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND SURE I VOTE AND
I DO HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK ON BEHALF
OF SAN MATEO COUNTY AND THE SAN
MATEO COUNTY ASSESSOR IN SUPPORT
OF SB -- TWO NINETY FOUR OUR
COUNTY HAS CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE AN UNPRECEDENTED
DEMAND FOR HOUSING WHICH HAS LED
TO SOME OF THE HIGHEST HOUSING
PRICES IN THE COUNTRY.
AND GIVEN THE SEVERITY OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CHALLENGES IN
OUR AREA IT IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER TO PRESERVE IN THIS IS.
WHICH FAMILY LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS DESPITE RECENT
ATTEMPTS TO INCREASE THE CAP AND
TO KEEP UP WITH THE INCREASING
PROPERTY VALUES THE CURRENT
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION CAP
LIMITS THE ABILITY OF THESE
TYPES OF NONPROFITS TO PROVIDE
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE CURRENT 90% LOW INCOME
TENDENCY REQUIREMENT LIMITS
CHARITIES LIKE SAINT FRANCIS
WITH A FEW MODERATE INCOME
TENANTS IN THE BUILDING FROM
BENEFITING FROM THE EXISTING
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION.
LOWERING THE REQUIRED PERCENTAGE
OF LOW INCOME TENANTS AND PRO
RATING THE EXEMPTION WOULD HELP
TO ALLEVIATE DISPLACEMENT THAT
CAN RESULT WHEN A CHARITY
PURCHASES A BUILDING WITH
EXISTING TENANTS AS WAS RECENTLY
THE CASE WITH THE STATE FOR
SAINT FRANCIS CENTER.
AND ALLOWS THEM TO USE THESE
FUNDS TO HELP MORE FAMILIES
SECURE AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT SB TWO
NINETY FOUR THANK YOU.
MANAGER MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION -- AS THOSE OF YOU IN
LA COUNTY MAY BE AWARE AGE OF
HIS ON EMBARKED ON A VERY
AGGRESSIVE -- HOUSING LOW INCOME
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT ON PROGRAM
WE CURRENTLY HAVE SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE UNITS OF LOW
INCOME HOUSING LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
ON TRACK -- TO TO GET UP TO
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND UNITS OVER
AND THERE IS NO GOVERNMENT
FUNDING AT ALL WERE -- CERTAINLY
CONCERN IN THE LONG RUN THAT THE
CURRENT TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR A
PROPERTY TAX CAP.
I'M WOULD LIMIT OUR ABILITY --
TO TO EMBARK ON THAT -- ON THAT
DEVELOP PROG.
A PROGRAM AS AGGRESSIVELY AS WE
WOULD LIKE -- WE APPRECIATE THE
HUNDRED MILLION THAT YOU ALL
AGREE TO APPRECIATE -- SENATOR
HELL MOVING THIS BILL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
TALKED QUIRK -- I'M KNOWN AS THE
GREEN RIVER REAPER ON THIS
COMMITTEE BUT I LOVE YOUR PAL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THERMAL AND ADDRESS BOOK THE
GRIM REAPER.
REMEMBER THAT -- ONE OKAY SO I
JUST HAVE A QUICK QUESTION JUST --
THE IS THIS A THIS ST FRANCIS IS
A SICK.
IS A PART OF THE CATHOLIC
CHARITIES OR SUBJECT DODGE
HAPPENS TO BE THE NAME NO I
THINK IT'S A I MEAN I'VE KNOWN
THEM FOR MANY YEARS IT IS JUST A
NAME I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S NOW
REALLY AREN'T AFFILIATION -- I
MEAN THE THE WOMAN WHO -- CAN
FACILITATES AND OPERATES AT THE
DIRECTOR OF IT IS -- IS A SISTER.
OF BUT NOT OF OF THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH I BELIEVE BUT IT'S NOT.
A PART OF THE CHURCH THIS IS A
SEPARATE NONPROFIT.
THEN THAT'S WHY IF IT WERE
CHURCH IT WOULD BE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT BUT I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
TO IT IS IT'S RUN BY A NUN.
AND A NINE IT SHE IS A NUN
SISTER CHRISTINA IS A NON.
BUT IT'S NOT A WITH AS WE CALL
CATHOLIC ORGANIZATION.
WHICH THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING IS
IS NOT THIS IS A A NON PROFIT
THAT SAFE FOR ONE C..
THREE IN IN CALIFORNIA IN THAT'S
IN BECAUSE OF ITS FOCUS ON A
SEPARATE FROM A EVEN FOR WORD
CHURCH SEPARATE FROM A CHURCH OR
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTION.
AND THAT'S WHERE IT'S REQUIRED
TO HAVE A LOT OF NODDING GOING
ON HERE DID I STRIKE A NERVE
SOME.
KNOW MORE ABOUT IT THAN I DO
YEAH I JUST I'M.
I MEAN IT'S CALLED SAINT FRANCIS
AND IS NOT BY ACCIDENT -- WAS A
FRENCH IS WHY NO I GO TO SAN
FRANCISCO CHURCH IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD TIME QUITE FAMILIAR
ST FRANCIS WHICH TELLS ME THAT
THIS WAS ON PURPOSE IT WAS NAMED
THIS WAY.
AND SO IT IS AFFILIATED WITH THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN SOME WAY AND
I'M JUST ASKING A IN ON WHAT IT
REALLY ASIAN IS IT IN.
IT IS A DISTINCT.
NONPROFIT AND AND I THINK THE
CONFUSION IS IS THAT -- IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY FOR THE BILL'S
PURPOSES IT'S NOT IMPORTANT
WHETHER IT'S FOR CATHOLIC CHURCH
OR OR ANYTHING ELSE IT'S FOR ANY
ORGANIZATION AS AS SOME OF THE
WITNESSES AS TESTIFIED TO AYE
THINGS IN OUR OFFICE.
IS A NON PROFIT IT'S NOT A ONE
OFF BILL IT'S NOT A ONE OF A BUT
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT'S
CLEAR I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
CONCERN WAS AS WE WERE NODDING
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S NOT A
ONE ALL I KNOW.
I UNDERSTAND THAT I MEAN I'M I'M
I'VE READ THROUGH IT I JUST IN
LITTLE -- CONCERNED ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT'S INTERESTING KELLER
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE IT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I DO WANT TO THANK A MARK
CHURCH WHO IS THE SAN MATEO
COUNTY ASSESSOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND IN HIS SUPPORT IN
THIS BECAUSE HE'S RECOGNIZES THE
THE NEED THAT -- THIS BILL WAS
WILL RESOLVE SO THANK YOU
APPRECIATE RESPECT YES RIVAL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
MANAGER I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM [inaudible]
EIGHT SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
SEVERAL CASKEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN.
THANK YOU MA'AM SURE MEMBERS AND
I TO UNDERSTAND THAT WOULD JUST
BE PRESENTING THIS AFTERNOON AND
AT THE PRO BRITTONUM -- THEY
CONSIDER YOU'LL CONSIDER OF VOTE
SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN WOULD
PROVIDE A STUDENT LOAN TAX
CREDIT FOR THE ENTIREAMOUNT OF
INTEREST A PERSON PAID ON THEIR
STUDENT LOAN -- THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR STUDENT LOAN DEBT IS NOW
THE SECOND HIGHEST CATEGORY OF
HOUSEHOLD DEBT IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA WITH OVER
FORTY FIVE MILLION BORROWERS
COLLECTIVELY -- IN ONE POINT
FIVE TRILLION DOLLARS MAKING IT
GREATER TEMPLE THE CREDIT CARD
DEBT AND AUTO LOAN GETS COMBINED.
THIS STATE IS DISPROPORTIONATELY
BORNE BY WOMEN.
IT'S STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES STUDENTS OF COLOR AND
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS THE BURDEN OF THESE
LOANS ON THESE PEOPLE HAVE
RESULTED.
IN A GENERATION POSTPONING
TRADITIONAL LIFE MILESTONES LIKE
BUYING A HOME GETTING MARRIED
STARTING A FAMILY AND SAVING FOR
RETIREMENT.
THE PURSUIT OF HIGHER EDUCATION
AND ADVANCED DEGREES IS HIGHLY
ENCOURAGED IN CALIFORNIA BUT THE
PRICE TAG FOR ATTENDING COLLEGE
IN THE NEED FOR STUDENT LOANS TO
COVER THOSE COSTS HAS GROWN
EXPONENTIALLY.
WELL INCOME GROWTH HAS REMAINED
STAGNANT.
IN PROVIDING THIS CREDIT SB FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN RECOGNIZES THE COST
CALIFORNIANS HAVE INCURRED IN
PURSUING HIGHER EDUCATION AND
PROVIDES SMALL MEASURE OF RELIEF.
SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN IS SUPPORT
BY THE CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
PARKS ASSOCIATIONS AND SILICON
VALLEY ASIAN PACIFIC AMERICAN --
DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN WITH ME I
HAVE CHRISTOPHER LONG AND
MICHAEL CUSTIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CHRIS FOR LONG AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY WAS SHEPHERD MULLIN BUT
I'M HERE TODAY SPEAKING IN MY
CAPACITY AS A DELEGATE FROM THE
CONFERENCE A CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS.
IN SUPPORT OF AS BEFORE.
SEVENTY SEVEN WE HAVE A CHOICE
TO MAKE.
DO WE WANT TO GIVE HIGHLY
EDUCATED INDIVIDUALS IN THE
STATE AN INCENTIVE TO REMAINING
CALIFORNIAN USE THEIR SKILLS
HERE.
BY PROVIDING MEANINGFUL RELIEF
FROM THE MOUNTAIN OF STUDENT
LOAN DEBT THEY FACE WITH THIS
BILL.
OR DO WE WANT TO STAND BY AND
WATCH THESE YOUNG MINDS LEAVE
FOR A HIGHER QUALITY OF LIFE
ELSEWHERE.
DUE TO THE CRUSHING COMBINATION
OF STUDENT LOAN DEBT
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH COST OF LIVING
THAT WE JUST HEARD ABOUT.
AND LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN MANY AREAS OF THE STATE.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A SOLUTION
THAT BREAKS FROM THE CURRENT
COOKIE CUTTER.
NATIONWIDE MODEL THAT APPLIES
EQUALLY TO SOMEONE LIVING IN SAN
FRANCISCO AS IT DOES TO SOMEONE
WHO IS LIVING IN NEBRASKA OR
SOUTH DAKOTA WHERE THE COST OF
LIVING IS SO MUCH LESS.
THE STUDENT LOAN CRISIS IS WELL
KNOWN AND NOT GOING TO BELABOR
IT HERE.
BUT IN JUST THE LAST TWELVE
YEARS IT HAS SKYROCKETED A
HUNDRED AND 57% FROM FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS TO MORE THAN ONE POINT
FIVE TRILLION DOLLARS TODAY. 40%
OF STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS ARE
EXPECTED TO DEFAULT ON THEIR
LOANS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ON A
PERSONAL NOTE I WORKED ALL
THROUGH COLLEGE TOOK TWO YEARS
OFF IN BETWEEN UNDERGRAD AND LAW
SCHOOL TO PAY DOWN MY OWN
PERSONAL STUDENT LOANS.
RECEIVED A NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLAR SCHOLARSHIP TO ATTEND LAW
SCHOOL.
AND WAS ABLE TO REFINANCE MY
LOANS THANKFULLY TO A MUCH LOWER
INTEREST RATE YET LAST YEAR
ALONE I PAID MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN
INTEREST PERSONALLY.
ON MY OWN STUDENT LOANS.
TUITION ALONE AT THE LAW SCHOOL
THAT I ATTENDED IS NOW MORE THAN
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR.
THAT DOESN'T IN COSTS THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE THE COST OF
LIVING.
BUT MY STORY IS HARDLY UNIQUE
FROM MY GENERATION AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO BE A VOICE FOR THAT.
AS THE BEST AND THE BRIGHTEST
TEACHERS DOCTORS ENGINEERS
LAWYERS AND SCIENTIFIC MINDS
CONTEMPLATE LEAVING THIS STATE.
WE HAVE A DECISION TO MAKE.
DO YOU WANT TO SIT BY.
WELL MORE AND MORE CALIFORNIANS
LEAVE.
WE'LL ALL LOSE OUT ON THAT
POTENTIAL TAX REVENUE.
OR DO WE WANT TO USE THIS BILL
AS A MEANS TO PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
RELIEF.
AND INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO STAY
HERE.
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE FOR AS
BEFORE.
SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU WE HAVE A
QUORUM IF WE CAN JUST PAUSE AND
WE DON'T -- SHE LEFT.
I WAS THIS CLOSE ALL RIGHT SO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT --
CONDITION GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL CASA SOME A
RESIDENT OF NEW YORK NEW YORK
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TO PART OF SB SOME.
FORTY SEVEN SB.
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN HOME PERSONAL
INCOME TAX CREDIT DEDUCTION FOR
QUALIFIED EDUCATIONAL LOANS.
AS A RECENT GRADUATE OF SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY MY STUDENT LOAN
DEBT.
EXCEEDS OVER ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS -- IN
LOANS.
WHEN I STARTED COLLEGE IN?
TWO THOUSAND NINE AT ENTERED
WITH THE G. D..
HELLO LOVE OF OF A LEGO LEVEL OF
EDUCATION.
THROUGH MY COLLEGE CAREER I
CHOSE -- TO CONTINUE ACQUIRING
AN ASSOCIATE OF ARTS BACHELOR OF
ARTS IN A MASTERS OF SCIENCE.
IN URBAN REGIONAL PLANNING A TON
OF THE STATE UNIVERSITY.
A RECENT GRADUATE ON MAY.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY NINETEEN A
AND I RECEIVED THREE CERTIFICATE
FOR MY MASTERS ONE IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ONE AND COMMUNITY DESIGN
AND DEVELOPMENT.
THE THIRD ENVIRONMENTAL PLANNING.
I'M CURRENTLY -- LOOKING FOR
EMPLOYMENT I HAVE CURRENTLY BEEN
WORKING PART TIME SINCE I'VE
GRADUATED.
I'VE HAD SOME LEADS BUT I'M
STILL CONCERNED ABOUT PAYING OFF
MY DEBT WHICH START -- TO MY
PAYMENT START IN DERRY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ACCORDING TO
MY NET NOW COUNT.
THE COST OF THE TO LIVE IN THE
BAY AREA HAS -- COST IT CAUSED
ME TO DRAW ON STUDENT LOANS OF A
COURSE FROM MY TENURE
EDUCATIONAL CAREER AS I STATED I
ENTERED COLLEGE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE WITH THE GT.
AFTER THOSE YEARS I USED UP MOST
OF MY FEDERAL GRANT LOAN SO I
HAD TO START WHEN I DECIDED TO
GO TO THE MASTERS OF URBAN AND
REGIONAL PLANNING I DECIDED.
TO DRAW LOANS IN ORDER TO REACH
MY GOALS -- AND GET A MASTERS IN
URBAN REGIONAL PLANNING.
I'M ONE OF THE FIRST STUDENTS --
ONE OF THE FIRST MEMBERS OF MY
FAMILY TO GET HIGHER EDUCATION
MY MOM AND DAD BOTH ONLY HAD.
HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE ARE HIGH
SCHOOL.
DIPLOMAS.
AND MY BROTHERS NONE NONE OF
THEM GRADUATED OTHER THAN HIGH
SCHOOL.
I DECIDED TO GO BACK WHEN I WAS
THIRTY EIGHT GOING ON THIRTY
NINE CRISIS IN MY LIFE AND YOU
KNOW RIGHT BEFORE THE TWO
THOUSAND NINE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN --
YOU KNOW WHEN I GOT INTO SAN
JOSE CITY COLLEGE A LOT OF MY
MENTORS -- ADVISED ME THAT I
SHOULD GO INTO HIGHER EDUCATION
AND CHOIR.
MY BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND AT THAT
TIME I WAS A STUDENT TRUSTEE AT
TEN OF THE EVERGREEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
IN A CHAPTER OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES
WAS ENCOURAGING THAT.
THROUGH THE BILLS ARE GOING TO
LEGISLATURE FOR THE STUDENT
SENATE FOR THE STUDENT SUCCESS
FACT.
THAT THEY NEEDED MORE PEOPLE TO
GRADUATE WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE RIGHT AND SO.
THAT ENCOURAGE ME AND AND TO GET
MY UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE IN.
THROUGH MY EDUCATIONAL.
COURSES AT TIMES A STATE I
DECIDED TO GET MY MASTERS DEGREE.
BUT I DIDN'T REALIZE AND AND
THAT I WAS GOING TO BE STUCK
WITH OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS WITH THE STUDENT LOAN
DEBT.
AND I'VE COME TO REALIZE THAT
THIS BILL WOULD GREATLY HELP NOT
ONLY ME.
BUT MILLIONS OF OTHER STUDENTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE OCCURRED DID ALONG THAT.
I'M SORRY.
CLEARLY I HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
SUPPORT THIS BILL NOT ONLY FOR
ME BUT FOR THE MILLIONS OF OTHER
STUDENTS.
THAT HAVE OCCURRED STUDENT LOAN
DEBT INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA.
I THINK YOU ADDITIONAL IN THIS
ISN'T SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
DOCTOR PARK -- SENATOR Y. CASKEY
YOU'VE BEEN MY FRIEND FOR A LONG
TIME.
MIKE IN TYPE TWO CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL FIRST OF ALL IT'S A NON
REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT.
AND ARGUABLY THE PEOPLE WHO NEED
THIS THE MOST NEED HELP THE MOST.
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T PAY
TASTES STATE TAXES BECAUSE THEIR
INCOME IS TOO LOW.
AND THOSE PEOPLE ARE LEFT
ENTIRELY OUT OF THIS.
THE OTHER THING IS THE COST IS
PRETTY HIGH IT'S A BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND I JUST WONDER IF THAT WOULD
BE BETTER SPENT REDUCING TUITION
AT STATE SCHOOLS.
ARE UP SCHOLARSHIPS AT CETERA SO
MY CONCERN IS THAT.
THIS DOES NOT GO THIS MONEY
WOULD NOT GO TO THE PEOPLE WHO
MOST NEED NAMELY THOSE PEOPLE
ARE MAKING TOO LITTLE INCOME. TO
PAY TAXES AND THEN.
YOU KNOW I JUST THINK THERE'S A
BETTER USE OF THE MONEY. THIRTY
CHAIR FIVE THERE'S THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT THE HIGH PRICE OF OF
OF A UNIVERSITY EDUCATION RIGHT
NOW IS IS PROHIBITING SOME
PEOPLE TO GO THE QUESTION IS IS
THIS MANY FOLKS IT'S A DIFFERENT
BATCH OF PEOPLE WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE PLANNING TO
GO TO SCHOOL OR MOVING FORWARD
IN SCHOOL.
WE WANT TO BRING THAT PRICE DOWN
THAT'S A CHALLENGE FOR ALL OF US
LEGISLATURE THE REALITY IS THAT
A WHOLE GENERATION OF PEOPLE ARE
STUCK WITH THE STUDENT DEBT.
THERE'S NO RELIEF FROM THEM EVEN
IF WE MADE.
UNIVERSITY FREE THEY WOULD STILL
BE STUCK WITH THEIR SIXTY
SEVENTY EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
SO THIS IS THIS IS DIRECTED AT
THAT CHUNK OF FOLKS WITH THE THE
PRICE TAG OF BILLION DOLLARS.
BUT THE OTHER QUESTION IS.
THE PEOPLE WHO NEED IT THE MOST
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE SO
LITTLE OF THEY DON'T PAY TAXES
IMAGINE A SINGLE MOM IS A
TEACHER.
DOES IT MAKE ENOUGH WITH
DEDUCTIONS TO PAY TAXES YOU'RE
NOT GIVING THAT PERSON A A BREAK
AT ALL.
OF THIS GENTLEMAN OVER HERE WHO
IS YET.
I THINK TO GET A PERMANENT JOB.
HE WOULD GET NO BREAK SELL THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT THE MOST.
WE GET NO BREAK FROM YOUR BILL
BECAUSE IT'S AND NON REFUNDABLE
TAX CREDIT.
YOU MAKE A GOOD POINT I GUESS
THE IN IN SHEER NUMBERS THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
STUDENT LOANDEBT ARE PEOPLE I
HAVE SOME IN COMMAND OF OF TAXES
AT THE PAIN BECAUSE THE THE
CHALLENGES THAT IF THEY HAVE
PAID ANY.
OF THEIR STIFF THERE THAT.
POR I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
THEY'RE PAYING BACK IN THEIR
THEIR THEIR STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
BUT THEY STILL OWE IT IN IF
YOU'D MAKE IT A REFUNDABLE TAX
CREDIT [inaudible]
AND IT WOULD DEFINITELY BE ABLE
TO HELP THAN THOSE FOLKS ON THE
POOR AND THANK YOU.
AT THIS YEAR I AND I BEGAN I'M
CHAIRING THE SENATE A SORRY THE
ASSEMBLY IS A SELECT COMMITTEE
ON STUDENT AT ODDS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
YOU DIGGING INTO THAT LOOKING
FOR SOME CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
HELP ALLEVIATE THE ENORMOUS
BURDEN OF STUDENT AT THAT SO
MANY PEOPLE EXPERIENCING.
I DO AGREE WITH DOCTOR PARK I
THINK THE MAKES A REALLY GOOD
POINT ABOUT.
MAYBETAKING A CLOSER LOOK AT IS
THIS THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
WAY TO ADD TO INAV TO SPEND WHAT
WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF
MONEY.
AND YOU KNOW ARE THERE OTHER
WAYS THAT WE CAN RELIEVE THE
BURDEN THAT WOULD BE MORE
EQUITABLE AND MORE EFFECTIVE.
HI I GUESS I GUESS OLD THROUGH
CHURCH THE SAME THING IT'S IT'S
THE POT OF WHETHER YOU'RE
LOOKING PROSPECTIVELY AT THE
COST OF EDUCATION WHICH IS
IMPORTANT AND BRING THAT DOWN SO
THAT YOU DON'T ENCOURAGED GET IN
FIRST PLACE.
AND THEN THE ONE POINT FIVE
TRILLION THE PEOPLE ARE ALREADY
IN DEBT WITH THERE'S NO PROGRAM
YOU KNOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CHANGE THE DISCHARGED REALTY OF
PRIVATE.
LOANS FIFTEEN YEARS AGO WHICH
CORRESPONDS TO THE BILL TRILLION
DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL DEBT
THAT'S GONE UP THAT'S NOT BY
ACCIDENT SO I'M JUST VERY
NARROWLY.
I WAS MORE REFERRING TO THE
POINT ABOUT YOU MAKING IT A
REFUNDABLE REFUNDABLE VERSES NON
REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT SAID THAT.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BENEFIT.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE LOWER
END OF THE INCOME SPECTRUM AS
WELL AS PEOPLE THAT.
KNOW THAT ARE EARNING AN INCOME
I WILL TAKE A IN DEPTH LOOK AT
THAT.
AND IT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
WILL FIND DOCTOR KIRK HAS
EDUCATED US ALL IN THIS
COMMITTEE ON AND WE HAVE FOUND
NORMALLY HE IS CORRECT ABOUT
THAT.
THE PROCESS OF THOSE WHO
ACTUALLY BENEFIT FROM SOME OF
THESE WERE SOME OF THESE TAX
CREDIT SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOUR OFFICE AND HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION WITH YOU.
UP RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A QUORUM
FOR REAL ACTUALLY THIS TIME SO.
MR HI ONLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WORK HERE.
GROW HERE CHIU [inaudible]
GRAY.
MAYES MELENDEZ MULLIN
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK HERE.
RIVAS.
TING.
WE HAVE A QUORUM I WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES I
WOULD WHEN YOU HAVE.
TIME -- TO TO CONSIDER THE
MEASURE I HOPE -- YOU LOOK AT IT
POSITIVELY AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
NUMBER ONE SB THREE OH NINE THIS
ITEM IS FOR REGULAR ORDER OF
BUSINESS.
SENATOR RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN.
OF THE BILL.
REAL QUICKLY JUST THANK YOU FOR
FOR HAVING ME HERE JUST --
WANTED TO PRESENT SB THREE
ONLINE WHICH WOULD REMOVE THE
MINIMUM DONATION REQUIREMENT
THAT THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
MUST RACE IN ORDER TO REMAIN
LISTED ON THE PERSONAL INCOME
TAX FROM.
FORM UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE OR CSL IS THE
STATUTORY AUTHORIZED BY YOU
DEDICATED TO ENHANCING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE. FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS AND IT ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS OVER THE AGE OF SIX
I'M SORRY FIFTY FIVE TO ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATE.
IN OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS AND
HELPS SHAPE POLICIES THAT AFFECT
THEIR LIVES.
THIS WONDERFUL PROGRAM BEGAN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THIS YEAR'S SO
HAS ALWAYS DEPENDED ON VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS VIA THE INCOME TAX
CHECK OFF.
WHICH HAS PROVIDED NEARLY ALL
FUNDING FOR ITS FOR I'M AN
ADVOCACY PROGRAM.
HOWEVER OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS THE CSO HAS RECEIVE LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND IN CONTRIBUTIONS AND
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE CSL
REMAINS.
ON THE VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS
LIST ONLY IF THE RECEIVED MORE
THAN -- TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND I DO HAVE A WITNESS IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IS THE YOU KNOW.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
COME ON UP.
ARE YOU IN SUPPORT -- COME
PLEASE RIGHT HERE TO THIS MY
GRAY HERE THANK YOU FOR COMING
TODAY.
ARE THE GUYS TALK FAST.
WORK FAST TOO I'M IN WARRANT THE
CHAIR OF THE LEDGE COMMITTEE FOR
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
AND I MET WITH MANY OF YOU.
IN OUR WORK AND I TELL YOU THAT.
AS A VOLUNTEER.
I VOLUNTEERED TO COME UP HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK TO YOU TO SAY I
TO WANT YOU TO PASS THIS
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL AT MRS IN SUPPORT.
HI AM ELEANOR BLOCK AND I BEEN
ON THE CSL SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR AND I HOPE THAT YOU DO
PASS THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
MR BRO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CENTER RUBIO IS THIS YOUR EXPERT
WITNESS.
I HAPPEN TO KNOW MISTER PORTER
HE'S THE SEVENTY THIRD ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE A GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE ALSO OUR PAST COMMANDER.
THE AMERICAN LEGION POST TWO
EIGHTY ONE AND AGAIN IN THE GAL
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THIS FOR
YEARS COULD SEE JOHN AND OF
COURSE BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
AFTER QUIRK.
SO WHAT IS THE MONEY USED FOR
THAT COMES THROUGH THIS
VOLUNTARY -- FIND.
VOLUNTARY DONATION FUND WHAT IS
IT USED.
FOR I'M GONNA LAST.
OUR EXPERT WITNESS TO SHARE THAT
WITH YOU OKAY SO HISTORICALLY IT
HAS BEEN USED TO FUND THE
ORGANIZATION POTH.
ROBBERY SIXPENCE AS AS WELL AS
THE ADVOCACY.
PIECE OF THAT WHICH INVOLVES OUR
ANNUAL SESSION AND MEETING WITH
LEGISLATORS TO FIND SPONSORS FOR
OUR BILLS.
AS YOU CAN SEE IN [inaudible]
TWENTY FOURTEEN SOMETHING
HAPPENED.
AND WE BEGAN TO THEN SEE
DIMINISHING RETURNS FROM THE
VOLUNTARY TAX CHECK OFF.
AND THEN WE BEGAN TO USE
TEMPORARY FUNDING.
THROUGH DOUBLE TRIPLE A ONE TO
FUND THE ORGANIZATION UNTIL WE
COULD RETURN. TO TAX CHECKOFF.
FUNDS TO ITS ORIGINAL STATE.
I PROVIDED A HISTORICAL
REFERENCE THAT SHOWED THE FROM.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE RIGHT UP
AND DOWNS.
AND THEN I ALSO PROVIDED
SOMETHING THAT SHOWED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AB
[inaudible]
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX THAT --
PROVIDED.
FOR I WILL REFER TO IT AS THE
CONTINUOUS FOR OUR FUNDING
THROUGH THE TAX CHECK OFF.
OF THE ANNUAL SESSION AND THE
LEGISLATOR VISITS [inaudible]
BUT WHAT.
ALL RIGHT IS IT WHAT IS IT
ACTUALLY PAYING FOR DON'T HAVE A
PERMANENT EMPLOYEE.
OKAY OKAY I HAVE -- EXPENSES
ASSOCIATED WITH OUR PRINTING
POSTAGE ARE THERE IS TRAVEL
INVOLVED IN BRINGING THE ALLEGE
COMMITTEE AND THE J. R. C. JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE WE THEN ALSO OR
INVOLVED IN. FOR SOMETHING
CALLED STATE FEES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE A STAFF TO
PERFORM ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS
LIKE HR ACCOUNTING FISCAL OUT WE
ARE CHARGED INSTEAD.
OF P..
THOSE FEES ARE ASSESSED AGAINST
US OKAY SO MY CONCERN IS SO --
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN YOU ONLY GOT.
A NINETY ONE THOUSAND THROUGH
APRIL OF THIS YEAR -- FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND MY CONCERN IS THIS
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH MONEY.
NOW YOU ARE A STATE DEPARTMENT
TAURUS STATE FUNCTION I THINK
THIS SHOULD COME OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND.
ARE THEY GIVE US TRAVEL MONEY
AND PER DIEM AND YOU KNOW WE
HAVE STAFF -- I THINK THIS WOULD
JUST BE A BETTER SOLUTION.
AND I WOULD BE GLAD TO LOOK INTO
THAT NEXT YEAR AS WE LOOK AT THE
BUDGET TRYING MAKE CASE FOR IT.
MY CONCERN HERE IS TWO FOLD ONE
IS.
THERE BEEN AN AWFUL LOT OF VERY
GOOD -- INSTITUTIONS -- EIGHT
THE LOU GEHRIG'S DISEASE
RESEARCH FIND MUNICIPAL SHELTERS
SPAY NEUTER FOND.
CALIFORNIA BILL POLICE
ACTIVITIES LEAGUE FUND WHICH
HAVE COME OFF.
AND I'M NOT SURE WHY THIS SHOULD
HAVE A A SPECIAL.
DISPENSATION WHEN WE DON'T GIVE
IT TO OTHERS -- I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE CONTINUE THIS --
BUT I'M I AM REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT THIS SETS
BECAUSE ALL OF THESE GROUPS THAT
COME OFF -- ARE WORTHWHILE
GROUPS FURTHER WE NOW HAVE A
LINE OF PEOPLE READY TO GO ON
WHEN OTHER PEOPLE COME OFF.
AND IF WE WERE TO GRANDFATHER IN
THE FOLKS THAT ARE IN THERE NOW --
IT HAS THE POTENTIAL FOR JUST
KEEPING.
OTHER GROUPS OFF SO THIS IS A
CONCERN I HAVE AND I REALLY DO
THINK.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THE NUMBERS
HAVE GONE DOWN FROM 200-500-0028
TO WHAT WAS IT.
NINETY YEAH NINETY THOUSAND LAST
YEAR TO FIFTY ONE THOUSAND SO
FAR THIS YEAR.
BUT I REALLY THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE AS A STATE
SHOULD BE FUNDING.
AND THAT'S SAD.
I THINK THAT'S GONNA BE IN THE
LONG RUN THE BEST WAY TO DO THIS
CONSIDERING THAT THE FUNDS JUST
AREN'T COMING MAN.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERN I'M I'M I UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT UP.
FIRST THIS YEAR SO HAS BEEN PART
OF THE ORIGINAL FOUR THERE WERE
ON THE TAX CHECKOFF IN SINCE
THEN.
THERE'S BEEN TWO HUNDRED CSL
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN ENACTED
AND SIGNED INTO LAW SO.
THEIR BODY OF WORK IN TERMS OF
REPRESENTING THE SENIOR
POPULATION EVERY WORKING TOWARDS
LEGISLATION THAT'S MEANINGFUL
AND YOU KNOW IT'S SOMETHING THAT
I I REALLY DO BELIEVE IN BUT HE
I'M GONNA LET HIM ANSWER THAT
THE PART IN TERMS OF THE FUNDING
SOURCES AND HOW IT'S BEEN.
DIMINISHING OVER THE YEARS --
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS.
JUST A REMINDER.
WE WERE.
WERE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET NOW.
420-192-0 OUR OKAY SO BUT WE BUT
THERE'S A THIS IS OUR PERCEPTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT.
WE ARE BEING GIVEN FUNDS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ASPECT OF THE
ORGANIZATION NOT THE ADVOCACY.
PIECE.
OUR SO WHAT MY NEXT.
POINT TWO THERE IS AND THEN WHAT
WE ARE.
POINTING OUT IS THAT WE WERE
ORIGINALLY ON THE TAX CHECK OFF.
AS ONE OF THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE NO MINIMUM.
SOMETHING HAPPENED IN THE
OTHER FUNDS WERE ADDED. TO THAT
STATUS WE SOMEHOW LOST.
THAT STATUS IT'S NEVER BEEN ABLE
TO REGAIN THAT.
THIRD JUST ANOTHER REMINDER --
WE'VE SEEN OUR REVENUE DIMINISH
BY OVER 80% WITH.
NO ONE ABLE. TO CONVEY TO US.
WHAT WHAT HAS TRANSPIRED AS YU
KNOW WE DON'T KNOW WHO THE
DONORS ARE?
THAT'S PROTECTED UNDER THE
FRANCHISE TAG ON THE RIGHT TO
PRIVACY RIGHT AND THAT WE'RE
WE'RE FACED WITH NOW IS.
ATTEMPTING TO RESURRECT.
THOSE AT DONOR BASE AND WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IS EACH TIME.
WE ARE NOT STATED WE LOSE A
POSITION WE WERE NUMBER TWO OR
NUMBER THREE ON THE TAX CHECK
OFF FOR YEARS.
HOW ACCORDING TO SENATOR MORLOCK
THIS PRESENTATION WITH REGARD TO
SB?
TWO FORTY ONE WE'RE ONLY DEALING
WITH A FINITE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ANYWAY.
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THE TAX CHECK
OFF IF HE'S RIGHT.
OUR AND SO.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT WHEN WE LOSE.
SKEWS ME IF WE LOSE OUR POSITION.
THEN WE START OVER AGAIN IN
TERMS OF OUR MARKETING.
BECAUSE WE'RE NO LONGER NUMBER
TWO OR THREE WERE NOW TWENTY
SEVEN OR TWENTY EIGHT OR
WHATEVER THE POSITION WILL BE
AND SO THE MARKETING AGAIN SLIPS.
AND YOUR RECOGNITION FACTOR IS
GONE AS WELL SO WOULD YOU WOULD
OPPOSE ME IF I WANTED TO ADD
MORE MONEY TO YOUR BUDGET NEXT
YEAR. ONE ISRAELI THAT THAT'S A
BETTER SOLUTION -- SINCE YOU ARE
SUNSET IN THIS IN -- TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE ALL I WILL SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY.
BUT I I I ASK YOU TO WORK WITH
ME NEXT YEAR AND TRYING TO GET
YOUR BUDGET.
INTO ALL OF YOUR FOR BUDGET INTO
THE GENERAL FUND I THINK IT
WOULD BE WORTHWHILE.
AREA I MEAN YOU KNOW I HAVE
STAFF.
THEY HELPED ME -- WORK FOR THE
THINGS THAT ARE MY GOALS -- I
THINK YOU SHOULD HAVE STAFF FOR
THAT AND I JUST THINK THAT'S A A
BETTER SOLUTION BECAUSE WE HAVE
NO IDEA WHY IT'S GOING DOWN AND
GOING DOWN PRECIPITOUSLY OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS -- BUT I
THINK THAT IN THE LONG RUN THAT
THAT WOULD BE A BIT BETTER
SOLUTION THANK YOU. SEVEN AWRY
WELCOME THAT OFFER.
A AND WILL LOOK FOR DOING THAT.
JUST ONE WATER REMINDER SO WE
HAVE EVEN RESORTED TO A VENDOR.
IN AN EFFORT TO TRY AND FIND
THAT DONOR PLACE.
STONE WE'RE WE'RE INCHING UP BUT
WE'RE WE'RE NOT GONNA HIT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND THIS YEAR
WITH FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
CURRENTLY IN THAT.
IT HAS ARE MAY RESULT IN.
IN MY HUMBLE OPINION SO THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR OFFER WILL
BE TALKING.
TO GREAT AND I'M SURE MR BRO
WILL BE -- WORKING WITH ME AS
WELL.
IT HAS ALWAYS [inaudible]
MR MAYES.
THE JUST QUICKLY I DIDN'T KNOW
IF THIS WAS PART OF THE REASON
WHY BUT I IS THERE SOME LEGAL
QUESTION ABOUT USING DOLLARS THE
TAX DOLLARS FOR ADVOCACY MAYBE
THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT IN THE
BUDGET WHY IT'S PART OF THE NOW
WHAT DOES YOUR STAFF DO ON YOUR
BILLS.
WELL THAT'S A LITTLE DO WELL
YEAH EXACT DATE THEIR STATE
STAFF IT'S A LITTLE IT'S A
LITTLE DIFFERENT SO I THINK THAT
MIGHT BE PART OF IT SO ANYWAY
WELL I I I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
WE SHOULD LOOK INTO.
I'M SORRY YES NO THAT'S OKAY
HERE THAT -- THAT'S OKAY I'M A
HANDLE THIS.
I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT WE CAN DO
THAT.
DOCTOR QUIRK AND MISTER BRO IF
THAT IF THEY SO CHOOSE CAN HELP
FIND A MORE SUSTAINABLE SOURCE.
FOR FOR YOU ALL STAFF SO WITH
THAT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATOR YES THANK YOU AND
I DO APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CORKS QUESTIONS OF COURSE YOU
KNOW WE ALL WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
WE'RE BEING FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
HERE BUT I JUST WANT TO SHOW
THESE LAST OUT THIS LAST PIECE
OF INFORMATION THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATES THAT THE BY BY THE
YEAR.
TWENTY THIRTY THE US STATE SIXTY
FIVE PLUS POPULATION WILL NEARLY
DOUBLE AND SO THAT MEANS THAT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE -- GROUPS LIKE -- JOHN
WORKING HARD TO ENSURE THAT WE
LOOK FOR POLICIES THAT ARE GOING
TO HELP THEM.
LIVE UP BETTER HEARING
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT ASKS FOR YOUR
RIFLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS HIGHLY CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO AGING
BURKE.
BURKE AYE BRO ROW I CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY.
GIVE ME MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S MELENDEZ AYE
MULLIN.
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS OUR
AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE RIVAS.
RIVAS I TING BILLS.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A FILE ITEM TO
THE QUé OR THE PILOT.
THEY CAN THANK FOUNDER.
I WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WITH HIGHLY CALLED.
THE SECOND WAS MAYES AND WHEN HE
MAKES I THINK.
THAT'S CORRECT -- WHICHEVER.
ONE THE CONCERN CAM -- SPEECH
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WE HAVE A WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. FOR THE PHONE ONLY ITEM
IS HIGHLY CALDERON.
FILE ITEM.
TEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
VETERANS AFFAIRS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO AREN'T YOU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
MAYES MAYES I'M LINDA THIS.
LINDISFARNE MOLEN PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I WORK.
ON QUIRK I RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE TING.
FABULOUS OUT ALSO THAT BILLS OUT
AS WELL CENTER GLAZER JUST GIVE
US ONE MORE MINUTE -- FILE ITEM
THREE SB -- SIX THIRTY SEVEN FOR
AS OUR LAST ITEM OF REGULAR
BUSINESS SENATOR REQUIRED TO ONE
OF PRESENT HE'S NOT LISTENING TO
ME.
END OF YOUR BILL.
AND IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
SO MUCH NO PROBLEM.
I WILL BE.
VERY QUICK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR
I'M GONNA BE I THINK YOU SO MUCH
BUT I'M SURE AND I APOLOGIZE
ABOUT KEEP YOU KNOW WAITING IN
WE DO APOLOGIZE ABOUT SESSION.
LONG STORY SHORT SB SIX THIRTY
SEVERAL EXPAND ACCESS TO FUNDING
FOR SPAY NEUTER PROGRAMS BY
ALLOWING NONPROFIT AND MORE
RESCUES AND SHELTERS TO APPLY
FOR THE PREVENTION AN ANIMAL
HOMELESSNESS AND CRUELTY
VOLUNTARY TAX CONTRIBUTION FIND.
LONG STORY SHORT IT'S A TAX
CONTRIBUTION FROM THE REYES IS
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND FOR SPAY NEUTER
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE.
WERE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT.
GRAY AT WHAT IS IN SUPPORT KAREN
LYING UNDER THE CALIFORNIA LAW
FOR SUSPICION WHICH REPRESENTS
ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE ANIMAL SHELTERS THE SAY
CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
TRANSPORT.
KAMALA CLARK AND I LIVE IN MARIN
AND I WANTED TO SAY AND THE TWO
FOR THIS GREAT I THINK YOU THANK
YOU.
I WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AS A GENTLEMAN IN OPPOSITION
KNOWS.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THEN WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AGAIN I DO APOLOGIZE ABOUT BEING
SO TARDY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
FLEXIBILITY MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK --
FOR NINE WITH THAT MISSILE IS
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE BY WORK ON
APRIL.
WELL I TO CHIU AYE GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES I'M MELINDA'S LINDISFARNE
MULLIN.
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS AYE
AYE QUIRK [inaudible]
I RIVAS.
THIS AYE TING THE BILL SO THAT
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT ON
FILE ITEM.
SIX SB TWO FORTY EIGHT I LOST MY
CROWD I LOST MY CROWD ON IT.
YOU WILL YOU DON'T HAVE.
TO MATTER TO VENTURE THANK YOU
FOR AYE HERE IN THIS BILL I KNOW
IT'S JUST A HEARING ONLY -- IT
BUT IT'S GOOD TO BE BACK BEFORE
YOUR COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS SIMILAR TO
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR THAT YOU
CONSIDERED AND MOVE FORWARD AND
I APPRECIATE RENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
RENTERS TAX CREDIT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO ONLY INCREASE ONCE.
SINCE THEN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
FORTY YEARS AGO.
AND OF COURSE SINCE THEN RENTS
HAVE FIVE GONE UP SUBSTANTIALLY
SOME CASES TRIPLED.
WHILE THE LEGISLATURE'S MADE
STRIDES IN EXPANDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING LITTLES BEEN DONE TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL RELIEF TO
THOSE WHO NEED IT THE MOST LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES STRUGGLING
WITH SKYROCKETING COSTS OF RENT.
IS INSTEAD OF DIFFERENTIATING
BETWEEN SINGLE AND JOINT -- FOR
FILERS THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE
THE CREDIT FOR THOSE WITH
DEPENDENTS.
MAKING THE CREDIT MORE HELPFUL
IN FAIR TO SINGLE MOMS DADS AND
FAMILIES.
THE BILL MAKES THE RENTERS TAX
CREDIT REFUNDABLE SO THAT EVEN
THOSE WITHOUT A TAX OBLIGATION
CAN RECEIVE THE BENEFITS OF THE
TAX CREDIT.
OUR THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
RENTERS WHO DON'T GET A CREDIT
TODAY TO GET ONE UNDER THIS BILL.
AND WHILE WE'RE DOING A LOT OF
CALIFORNIA TO TRY TO ADVANCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
A LOT OF THAT IS GOING TO TAKE
TIME.
AND HAVE A RENTERS TAX CREDIT
CAN HELP SOMEBODY ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY.
AND IT IS SUBJECT TO THE BUDGET
AX SO -- THIS ONLY PROVIDES AN
AUTHORIZATION AND EVERY YEAR WE
HAVE THE CHANCE TO TO MAKE A
CHOICE AS TO WHETHER WEWANT TO
SUPPORT THAT -- CREDIT -- IN THE
IN THE BUDGET YOU'RE GIVEN OUR
BUDGET CIRCUMSTANCES.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS --
LEWIS -- MAYOR MIRANTE TAKE.
FROM CALIFORNIA ME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
LUIS MONTERO COMPANY M. B. I
HERE AT TO SUPPORT I SB TWO
FORTY EIGHT I THINK THE SENATOR
DID A WONDERFUL JOB OF RECAPPING
WHAT.
THE BILL IS INTENDED TO DO BUT
MAYBE I COULD JUST PROVIDE A
LITTLE CONTEXT FOR HOW THE STATE.
TYPICALLY SPENDS ITS TAX
EXPENDITURES ON THE ISSUE OF
HOUSING.
STILL IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES MOST RECENT
TAX EXPENDITURE REPORT.
YOU'LL FIND THAT JUST IN THE
CATEGORY OF INCOME TAX
EXEMPTIONS WHICH THIS WOULD BE.
THERE IS ABOUT TWELVE POINT SIX
SIX BILLION DOLLARS -- ALLOCATED --
FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP TAX
EXPENDITURE ACTIVITIES SPREAD
ACROSS THE SIX POINT NINE ONE
HOME ON OCT OWNER OCCUPIED HOMES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S ABOUT ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO DOLLARS -- PER HOME.
IN IN IN THAT SAME DOCUMENT GO
FIND A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED FOR
THE RENTERS -- TAX CREDIT AT THE
EXISTING ONE WHICH SPREAD ACROSS
THE FIVE POINT -- EIGHT ONE
RENTER MILLION RENTER OCCUPIED
HOMES IS ABOUT TWENTY TWO
DOLLARS AND THIRTY EIGHT CENTS --
SO A PRETTY BIG DISPARITY THERE --
WE'RE SUPPORTING AS BE TWO FORTY
EIGHT FOR THE REASON THAT IT
PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED RELIEF
TODAY -- AND HELPS CLOSE THAT
GAP.
I STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE THE
THANK YOU IT IS NO IN IS IS IN
SUPPORT. TWENTY BE WITH THE A
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SO SHE CAN
HEAR SUPPORT.
TIM CAMERA WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIC ADVISERS IN SUPPORT
THANKS.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BOB NEARING BATTLEFIELDS
STIRLING COMPANY IN SUPPORT.
IN THE GOING WITH CAPITAL
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
ROSANNA CARPACCIO -- ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA ALSO IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
WHEN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
A CELL ASSEMBLY ARLAND AS WE'RE
GONNA MIX IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
THANK YOU THE GRIM REAPER HAS TO
WAIT A MINUTE -- SO I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AGAIN I THINK YOU
KNOW WE ALL RECOGNIZE ON THIS
COMMITTEE IN IN THESE CHAMBERS
AT THIS HOUSING ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE -- THE AFFORDABILITY ISSUE
IS A MULTI PRONGED APPROACH IS
NOT JUST ONE THING I WISH IT WAS
OR WE COULD DO THAT BUT THIS
THIS CERTAINLY IS GOING TO HELP
THEIR A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE.
WHO CHOOSE NOT TO BUY A HOME
UNDER A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE
WHO CAN'T AFFORD HOME RIGHT NOW
BUT REGARDLESS WE HAVE A LOT OF
RENTERS OUT THERE?
AND WE REALLY DO NEED TO BRING
THESE IDEAS FORWARD AND TRY TO
HELP PEOPLE STAY IN THE
RESIDENTS AT THE RAN -- AND HELP
THEM PERHAPS WORK TOWARD HOME
HOMEOWNERSHIP BUT THIS IS THE
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT SEEMS TO BE
LEFT OUT A LOT ARE THE RUNNERS
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
AND I'M SURE YOU'LL ENJOY WIDE
SUPPORT.
SHIP DOCTOR QUIRK.
SO MY CONCERN HERE IS JUST THE
LAWS OF ECONOMICS.
SO YOU HAVE A DEMAND CURVE IN
SUPPLY CURVE.
MY CONCERN IS THAT THIS INCREASE.
IN.
MONEY AVAILABLE TO RANCHERS WILL
SIMPLY RESULT IF THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH SUPPLY OF RENTAL HOUSING
WHICH THERE ISN'T [inaudible]
THAT BASICALLY.
I MEAN I HATE TO SAY THIS BUT
READ THE PEOPLE WHO OWN THE
HOUSING.
ARE GOING TO SAY WELL NOW WE CAN
CHARGE MORE.
AND THE PEOPLE HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE MONEY AND YOU CAN CHARGE A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
SO MY CONCERN IS THAT THIS WOULD
ALL BE TAKEN UP.
IN THE FACT BY THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALREADY TAKING IN THE RANTS.
AND SO THAT'S ONE OF MY CONCERNS
THE OTHER IS THAT IT'S SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
AND ARE THERE BETTER WAYS TO
HELP OUT RANCHERS.
YOU ALSO BRING UP THE ISSUE OF
ALL THE MONEY THAT IS SPENT ON
HOMEOWNERS.
I WOULD BE IN FAVOR OF ACTUALLY --
OVER TIME WE ARE THE ONLY
DEVELOPED COUNTRY.
THAT ALLOWS HOMEOWNERS THOSE TAX
BREAKS IN BRITAIN DAVE -- TAKEN
THEM OUT.
ARE THEY DID IT OVER A PERIOD OF
YEARS SO PEOPLE AT TIME TO
ADJUST.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE AN
EXTREMELY FAIR THING TO DO I
DON'T EXPECT THAT IT'S GOING TO
PASS ANYTIME SOON -- BUT I DO
AGREE WITH YOU THERE IS A BIG --
DISCREPANCY HERE BETWEEN HELPING
THE MORE WEALTHY FOLKS.
BUT THERE'S ALSO A QUESTION
ABOUT.
THE PRICE OF THESE HOMES FOR
EXAMPLE MY SON IS LOOKING AT A
HOME IN REDWOOD CITY.
ARCHERY HALFWAY BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND SAN JOSE WHERE HE
AND HIS WIFE TO BE LIVE.
THE STAR HOME IS A MILLION AND A
HALF.
I'M WILLING TO BET THAT IF WE
DIDN'T ALLOW TAX DEDUCTIONS ON
THAT THE PRICES WOULD GO DOWN SO
WHAT I'M SAYING HERE IS THAT I'M
WORRIED THAT ALL OF THE SLACK.
WHICH SIMPLY ALL OF THIS
ADDITIONAL MONEY WOULD BE TAKEN
OUT BY THE PEOPLE AROUND THE
HOUSING.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ANSWER.
HAPPY TO HAVE CHAIRS PERMISSION
OF COURSE I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
YOUR ANALYSIS ABOUT SUPPLY AND
DEMAND IT'S REALLY THE BIG IT'S
THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM AND
WE'RE CERTAINLY WORKING AT A
FROM A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE AND HAVE
FOR FOR A COUPLE YEARS.
BUT IT'S SLOW TO HAVE ITS EFFECT
BUT LISTEN IF YOU'RE A RENTER IN
YOUR PAIN 506070%.
OF YOUR INCOME ON RENT.
AND A BILL LIKE THIS COMES ALONG
WITH ALLOWS YOU TO KEEP TO GET
INSTEAD OF HAVING A SIXTY DOLLAR
CREDIT.
BUT TO GO UP TO FOURTEEN THIRTY
FOUR THAT THAT'S GONNA BE THAT'S
GONNA BE A BIG HELP TO YOU AND
IS IT GOING TO CHANGE THE THE
PROFIT CURVE FOR A A LANDLORD.
LOOK EVERYONE AND IS GOING TO
MAKE THEIR OWN CHOICES IN THE
MARKET PLACE FOR THAT YOU KNOW
WE CAN'T CONTROL THAT.
BUT I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO
HELP A LOT OF PEOPLE AND IN
UNDER THIS BILL YOU'RE GONNA
HELP TWO POINT FOUR MILLION.
I THE LOWEST END OF THE ECONOMIC
SCALE WHO ARE SUFFERING THE MOST
SO DO WE NEED TO BUILD MORE --
OF HOUSING OF COURSE.
BUT WE HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING AND
FORTY YEARS TO HELP THOSE IN THE
LOWEST AND ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH
THAT SINGLE MOMS AND DADS THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE THAT REFORM
IN THE LAW.
IT'S NOT THERE TODAY AT THE
COULD BE VERY HELPFUL.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THEM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I KNOW IT'S NOT A
DECISION POINT TODAY.
AND I ALSO WOULD JUST RECOGNIZE
AGAIN THAT.
THESE THINGS ARE SUBJECT TO THE
BUDGET WE NOW WE HAVE LOTS OF
CHOICES IN THAT IN THAT
FRAMEWORK.
BUT WE CAN PERFORM THE CREDIT TO
HELP SINGLE MOMS AND DADS IN
THIS BILL AND THEN HOPEFULLY
WITH THE RIGHT -- ECONOMY AND
AND CHOICES THAT WE CAN FIND AT
EACH YEAR AND MAKE GOOD CHOICES
THERE THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
MOVING THE FINAL NINE SB FIVE
TWENTY ONE SENATOR PORTANTINO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
.
MY READING SORRY THANK YOU AYE
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I'M
PRESENTING SB.
FIVE TWENTY ONE WHICH WOULD
ALLOW A TAX CREDIT TO A TAXPAYER
THAT OWNS THE PROPERTY RENTED TO
OR AT LEAST FIVE PERSONS
RECEIVING ASSISTANCE UNDER
SECTION.
EIGHT THE UNITED STATES HOUSING
ACT OF NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN AN
AMOUNT EQUAL 23% OF THE AMOUNT.
OF RENT OR LEASE PAYMENTS AND
LIMITED TO FIVE QUALIFIED
PROPERTIES PER TAXPAYER PER
TAXABLE YEAR -- WE KNOW THERE'S
A HOUSING SHORTAGE WE THINK THIS
IS AN INCENTIVE BASED PROGRAM
I'LL JUST GIVE YOU ONE STATISTIC
THEN THE CITY OF PASADENA -- THE
NUMBER OF PROPERTIES THAT WERE
TAKING SECTION EIGHT THIS PAST
YEAR DECREASED BY ONE HUNDRED SO
THAT WAS A SERIOUS IMPACT.
I THEY WERE FROM.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED TO TWELVE
HUNDRED WE SEEK TO TRY TO
PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE AND EVEN
OUT THE ECONOMICS.
OF IT AND SO WE THINK THIS IS A
GOOD APPROACH AND WOULD LOVE TO
SET UP THE FRAMEWORK.
AND AGAIN -- DISCUSS IT IN EACH
BUDGET YEAR GOING FORWARD WITH
ME I HAVE PETERS -- BACK
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
GLENDALE WHICH BROUGHT THE IDEA
TO MY ATTENTION AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I AM SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU --
I THINK THE CENTER DID A VERY
GOOD JOB AND AND PUTTING THE
ISSUE FORWARD.
I WOULD ONLY LIKE TO ADD THAT
FOR MANY LANDLORDS THE DECISION
TO ACCEPT A SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHER.
INTO THEIR PORTFOLIOS MOTIVATED
PRIMARILY ON A COST BENEFIT
BASIS AND IN THIS TIGHT HOUSING
MARKET OF LANDLORDS ARE OPTING
TO LOOK.
AT THOSE THAT COULD PAY THE
HIGHER RENT WE'VE SEEN MANY
CASES IN WHICH TENANTS THAT
WE'VE ISSUED VOUCHERS TO GO OUT
TRY TO CONTRACT UP OF UNITS.
COME BACK TURN THEIR VOUCHER
BACK IN AFTER WAITING YEARS ON
THE WAITING LIST PROGRAM SAY
THEY'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO SECURE
UNIT.
MAINLY DUE TO THE RIGHT LEVELS
THAT ARE DICTATED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL IN THIS FORMULA.
WE THINK THAT THIS TARGETED TAX
INCENTIVE WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP
PLACE SECTION EIGHT TENANTS IN
CALIFORNIA -- ON A CLOSER TO
EQUAL GROUND -- IT WHEN WHEN
THEY ARE OUT THERE -- TRYING TO
SECURE UNIT WITH THEIR SECTION
EIGHT VOUCHER.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY TO PASS THE
NUMBER BANK ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. TWENTY BOY
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SO
SHE'S NEAR SUPPORTERS WILL.
TIM CAMERA WE HAVE A CALPERS TO
TAKE ADVISORS REPRESENTING
SEVERAL RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CREAM THREE CM HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
WHEN YOU GO OVER IN CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU?
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS WITH ME DOCTOR QUIRK
YEAH I I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
BILL BECAUSE YOUR YOUR THE MONEY
IS TARGETED. TO THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT THE MOST SO THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
WHEN APPROPRIATE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU --
DURING -- MEMBERS [inaudible]
HOME AGAIN [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SEARCHING.
I CONSENT CALENDAR ON IT IT IS
GOING TO GIVE CONSENT OVERS.
ARE LIVING THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEM TO SB -- FIVE SEVEN
SEVEN KILEY OF SOMETHING.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER ONE SB THREE
OH NINE CALL YOU HVE CITIES
THAT BILLS I'LL.
RETAIN.
TING I FILE ITEM THREE SB SIX
THIRTY SEVEN CALL THE ABSENTEES
TING.
TING I WE ARE ONLY REALLY FILE
NUMBER TEN SB [inaudible] SIX
SIXTY THREE THREE NINE THREE TWO
SIX SIX THAT WAS THE VOTE ONLY
THAT YOU JUST VOTED HONEST AND
TEN I TO SEE MR HERTZBERG WHICH
I
OKAY START MOVING OF A
STARTING WITH CONSENT.
SB FIVE SEVEN SEVEN CALL THE
ABSENTEES MULLIN.
HI INLAND I GRAY [inaudible]
GRAY AYE.
FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE OH NINE
CALL THE ABSENTEES GRAY.
GRAY I AM MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE FILE ITEM THREE SB
SIX THIRTY SEVEN CALL THE
ABSENCE.
GRAY.
GRAY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE.
FILE ITEM TEN SB.
SIX SIXTY THREE GRAY HI RAY I
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE [inaudible]
BY.
THEY LOOK LIKE THE TICKET
[inaudible]
AREAS [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE TO FILE ITEM FOR SB SIXTY
THREE WELCOME SENATOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN FILL ALL OF THE
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OKAY.
ARE YOU READY [inaudible]
HI [inaudible] TO HOW TO THE
SAME CHAIRS AT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO [inaudible]
DIFFERENT COMMITTEE.
THIS IS FANTASTIC BY THE WAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
SO ON UNDER THE WHAT HAPPENS IN
IN INSTANCES WHERE ARE THESE
PEOPLE FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS GO
BANKRUPT AND GO OUT OF BUSINESS.
ARE OFTEN THERE'S STUDENT AT THE
GETS RELIEVED ARE.
AT STUDENT AT THE THE THE THE
TAX LIABILITY -- DISHES MADE
STUDENT DEBT GETS RELIEVED AND
THEN THERE'S A TAX LIABILITY
BECAUSE OF THE RELIEF OF DEBT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
HAS HAS BASICALLY COME UP WITH A
LAW THAT UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES THERE'S NO FEDERAL
TAX LIABILITY IN THE STATE
SITUATION WE WE STILL OF TAX
LIABILITY SO WHEN WE HAD THE
CORINTHIANS SCHOOL.
IT BACK A FEW YEARS AGO -- GOLD
GO BANKRUPT -- WE PASSED A
MEASURE.
ARE ON THAT COST.
AND THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IS IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
CURRENT IN COLLEGE.
THIS BILL CAME OUT OF MY
DISTRICT WE HAVE A BRIGHT WOULD --
SCHOOL THAT WENT BANKRUPT AND
THEN ADDITION WE'VE LEARNED AT
THE ART INSTITUTE DROUGHT
CALIFORNIA HAS GONE BANKRUPT AND
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
ASKING THAT OF THE STUDENTS THAT
ARE GETTING DEBT RELIEF NOT TO
HAVE -- TO TO PAY -- ON TAXES ON
THAT DEBT RELIEF.
IT'S THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ESTIMATES OF THE COST IS ONE
POINT TWO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AND THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS I
DON'T HAVE THE CURRENT IN
COLLEGE BUT WITH RESPECT TO BOTH
BRIGHT WITH A TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE STUDENTS.
AND ART INSTITUTE ABOUT TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED STUDENTS FOR A
TOTAL OF FIVE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY AND STUDENTS SO
IT'S REALLY JUST KIND OF A AN AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF RELIEF FOR
THE STUDENTS TO FIND THEMSELVES
IN A QUITE DIFFICULT POSITION.
AND TO MAKE IT EVEN WORSE TALK
ABOUT INSULT TO INJURY TO BE IN
A SITUATION WHERE YOU'RE TELLING
THESE KIDS THAT -- WILL GUESS
WHAT YOU GOT A TAX BILL IN YOUR
DEBT RELIEF FEDS DON'T DO IT WE
SHOULDN'T DO IT THAT'S MY ****
BUT AS HE PASSES BILL.
THANK YOU THIS IS AN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS FOR THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING HERE MY NAME
IS BRANDON BIGGER THAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT A COMMISSION
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL JUST AS
WE DID.
WITH THE PREVIOUS BILL FOR THE
CORINTHIAN STUDENTS I'M ONE OF
MY RESPONSIBILITIES AND
PRIVILEGES REALLY WITH THIS YOU
NAY COMMISSION IS INTERACT WITH
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY AFTER
INSTANCES LIKE THIS HAVE
OCCURRED.
AND ONE OF THE HARDEST DAYS THAT
I'VE HAD IS GOING TO A COMMUNITY
EVENT WHERE WE WERE TRYING TO
HELP STUDENTS AT CURRENTLY IN
COLLEGE CAMPUSES THAT HAD CLOSED
DOWN.
SEEK A PATH FORWARD AND FIGURE
OUT HOW THEY WERE GOING TO GET
FROM WHERE THEY ARE FIGURE OUT A
TRANSFER THE CLASSES FIGURE OUT
HOW TO REGAIN SOME FINANCIAL AID
ELIGIBILITY FIGURE OUT HOW TO
PAY FOR A NEW SCHOOL.
AND IN MANY CASES THESE ARE
STUDENTS WHO ARE RIGHT UP AT THE
EDGE OF GRADUATION WHEN THE
CAMPUS IS SHUT DOWN AND THEY'RE
LEFT WITH NO WAY TO PAY FOR
ANOTHER COLLEGE DEGREE
ESSENTIALLY RIGHT.
AND THESE ARE STUDENTS WHO START
SCHOOL OFTEN LATER IN LIFE A
SECRET TRAINING A NEW CAREER AND
SO THERE AND ESPECIALLY DIRE
STRAITS AND BEING HIT WITH A TAX
BILL AS A ALMOST A PENALTY FOR
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF A
RESTORATION OF YOUR STUDENT LOAN
ELIGIBILITY -- FURTHER -- PUTS
DILEMMAS IN FRONT OF THEM AND SO
WE FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL WE
WANT TO REMOVE ALL THE VARIOUS
FROM THE STUDENTS PASS FORWARD
AND HELP THEM.
BE ABLE TO ATTAIN A COLLEGE
DEGREE AND SUPPORT THAT COMES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
ARTWORK.
GREAT BILL.
THANK YOU SIR PRESERVER MUCH I
WILL GREAT BILL SECOND THAT AND
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU SAYS
FOR AN AYE VOTE THE TIME YOU
MAKE A CONSIDERATION OF THIS
BILL HAVE CONSIDERATIONS MISSION
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BUT WE DONE YOU GUYS
TRANSMISSION.
WE ARE WE GOING TO STRUCTURE
SOMETHING
[inaudible]
SIX ONE WE
ARE GOING TO GIVE SENATOR ABOUT
FIVE MINUTES -- 2% ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SB ONE NINETY SIX IF NOT WE
WILL MOVE IT OVER TO THE NEXT
HEARING WILL DO FIVE MINUTES
FROM NOW
. FOR MOVING FILE ITEM
FIVE SB ONE NINETY SIX OVER TO
NEXT WEEK THANK YOU THE MEANS TO
TURN [inaudible]
YEAH
.
SEE WE CAN.
EXPORT.
I'LL.
HAVE SOMEONE.
INFORM PEOPLE ENOUGH